[Musique]
le dernier rapport du groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat le giec est sans équivoque
si on veut contenir la hausse des
températures il faudra des mesures
musclées
les changements climatiques ont déjà des
impacts réels sur l'agriculture et
paradoxalement l'agriculture fait à la
fois partie du problème et de la
solution
revoyez notre entrevue avec un expert
mondial du climat qui ne mâche pas ses
mots nous menaçons l'habitabilité même
de notre planète
les vagues de chaleur se multiplient la
glace de mer il et glaciers sont en
recul
les précipitations intenses deviennent
de plus en plus fréquentes
aujourd'hui nous utilisons l'atmosphère
comme une grande poubelle gratuite
le belge jean-pascal van ypersele est un
homme investi d'une mission faire
comprendre l'urgence de la crise
climatique dans le domaine climatique on
va vers un mur on n'arrête pas de le
dire et on n'a toujours pas commencé
vraiment à freiner puisque les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre continuent à
augmenter alors qu'elles devraient le
plus vite possible diminué mais
m'arriver à 0 bien avant la fin de ce
siècle pour l'agriculture dont
l'humanité entière dépend pour se
nourrir
les changements climatiques sont une
bombe à retardement l'agriculture s'est
développé au fil des millénaires dans un
climat données bien si ce climat devient
très différents c'est ce qui est en
train de se passer mais forcément ça va
avoir des impacts sur l'agriculture
mais ces impacts sont déjà visibles des
saisons sèches qui s'étire des mousson
dévastatrice en afrique par exemple où
le climat est déjà chaud une once de
quelques degrés est synonyme de
catastrophe
ce continent compte déjà des centaines
de millions personnes qui souffrent de
la faim et la majorité d'entre elles
sont des paysans
la plupart des espèces qui sont cultivés
en afrique sont très proches de leurs
limites de tolérance en termes de
température et donc les rendements en
afrique risque de diminuer beaucoup plus
vite que les rendements aux latitudes
moyennes dont celle du canada
et finalement c'est très injuste parce
que les paysans africains sont beaucoup
moins responsable entre guillemets du
dérèglement du climat que nos pays
riches que ce soit le canada ou la
belgique
en ce qui me concerne dans un pays
septentrionale comme le canada certains
entrevoient des effets bénéfiques liés
au changement climatique
une saison de culture plus longue
pourrait se traduire par des récoltes
plus abondante un climat plus chaud
permettrait également d'adopter de
nouvelles variétés plus rentables
mais selon jean-pascal van ypersele
l'équation dit pas si simple il faut pas
simplement se focaliser sur le fait
qu'avec une température un peu plus
élevée automatiquement tous les
rendements deviendrai supérieur il peut
y avoir dans le cadre de ce dérèglement
du climat toute une série de raisons de
s'inquiéter
[Musique]
il cite en exemple l'arrivée de
ravageurs de plantes envahissantes et de
maladies qui proliféraient dans un
climat plus chaud et auquel nos cultures
sont mal adaptés sans compter la
multiplication des événements
climatiques extrêmes qui causent déjà du
tort aux récoltes
mais pour des populations entières les
changements climatiques sont une menace
existentielle
le réchauffement des températures
entraîne la fonte des glaces
continentales et des glacis le phénomène
de dilatation thermique fait en sorte
que l'eau plus chaude
aucun un plus grand espace depuis 100
ans le niveau des mers a déjà monté de
près de 20 cm
ce sont des centaines de millions de
personnes qui vont devoir
me grey regardez le delta du nil par
exemple vous avez plus de 10 millions de
personnes qui habitent à moins d'un
mètre au dessus du niveau de la
méditerranée
si le niveau monde ne fut-ce que d'un
demi mètre ce qui va se passer dans les
quelques décennies qui viennent ce sont
des millions de personnes qui ne
pourront plus pratiquer l'agriculture
parce que s'ils sont là on parle
d'agriculture c'est parce que ce terrain
est fertile et ce terrain fertile va
être inondé par de l'eau salée bien
avant la fin de ce siècle
si l'agriculture subira de plein fouet
les effets des changements climatiques
elle est aussi en partie responsable du
problème
c'est un secteur très énergivores mais
parmi toutes les activités agricoles
c'est l'élevage qui s'avère le plus
polluant
selon la ffa ou l'organisation des
nations unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture l'élevage produit à lui
seul 14,5 pour cent des émissions
globales de gaz à effet de serre
à l'échelle mondiale c'est plus que le
secteur des transports
tous les animaux qui rumine que ce soit
les vaches les boeufs par exemple et
bien maîtres du méthane dans leur
processus de digestion et ce méthane est
aussi un puissant gaz à effet de serre
chaque kg de méthane émis correspond à
le même effet qu'à peu près 30 kg de co2
et donc là aussi il y a un effet des
activités liées à l'élevage dans ce
cas-ci sur le climat mondial
l'utilisation massive d'engrais azotés
est aussi montré du doigt elle conduit à
des émissions de protoxyde d'azoté n2o
un autre puissant gaz à effet de serre
chaque kilo de n2o à peu près le même
effet que 300 kg de co2 donc c'est un
autre lien entre agriculture et
dérèglements du climat
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il y a des
solutions
les agriculteurs ont sous les pieds un
immense puits de carbone le sol celui ci
a la capacité d'absorber d'énormes
quantités de co2 mais chaque fois qu'on
le labour on relâche du co2 dans
l'atmosphère et pratiques culturales qui
réduisent au maximum le travail du sol
comme le semis direct qui consiste à
semer sans avoir labouré au préalable
peuvent donc avoir un impact
considérable
aux états unis on a calculé que de 1974
à 2008
le semis direct a permis d'éviter le
rejet de 241 millions de tonnes
métriques de co2 ça équivaut aux
émissions de 50 millions de voitures par
année
modifier le régime alimentaire des
ruminants pour qu'ils produisent moins
de gaz à effet de serre est une autre
piste de solution et la balle est aussi
dans le camp des consommateurs
si on mange beaucoup de viande qui vient
de ruminants par exemple mais forcément
on va créer une demande pour qu'il y ait
davantage d'élevage avec ses
conséquences sur les émissions de
méthane si on a une alimentation qui est
- carnets qui est davantage végétarienne
ou au moins partiellement végétarienne
vie on contribue quelque part à une
diminution de ses émissions puisque on
ne passe pas par ces ces ruminants qui
émettent beaucoup de méthane
de la ferme jusqu'à l'assiette on peut
aussi lutter contre les changements
climatiques en évitant le gaspillage
alimentaire le tiers de toute la
nourriture produite dans le monde est
gaspillé la production la récolte le
transport la réfrigération la
transformation et la décomposition de
ces aliments voué à la poubelle entraîne
une énorme quantité de gaz à effet de
serre si le gaspillage alimentaire était
un pays il serait le troisième plus
important émetteur de gaz à effet de
serre au monde juste après la chine et
les états unis
on a compris d'où venait le problème on
a compris que ce réchauffement venaient
principalement des activités humaines et
je crois qu'il faut considérer cela
comme une bonne nouvelle
les changements climatiques sont sans
doute l'un des plus grands défis
auxquels l'humanité fait face ils
affecteront les sécurité alimentaire et
par conséquent la stabilité du monde et
plus on attend plus les coûts associés
au réchauffement du climat
grain jean-pascal van ypersele demeure
malgré tout optimiste nous connaissons
désormais la cause de ces perturbations
et nous avons même les moyens de les
atténuer je crois en l'humain je pense
que nous avons la capacité
nous avons les connaissances nous avons
si nous le voulons la possibilité d'agir
dans la bonne direction quand on quand
on le veut et bon 7 milliard et demi de
personnes qui bouge dans la bonne
direction
ça fait beaucoup de monde donc si nous
voulons nous pouvons comme l a dit
quelqu'un d'autres avant moi
[Musique]